joining us now president Trump's
attorney former New York City Mayor Rudy
Giuliani mr. mayor before you took on
this position you had on this program
identified crimes I think it is
extraordinarily relevant how the upper
echelon and the FBI treated Hillary
Clinton so she could survive without
being indicted as a candidate and how
they have treated Donald Trump and I do
believe this impacts whether or not the
Muller investigation at its foundation
considering it's the same people
involved now should all go away as a
result Shawn you're absolutely right I
was on your show about a year and a half
before the election we identified I
think it was 18 violations of the law by
Hillary Clinton none of which call me
and his fix
were able to prove and and it's
disgraceful but we're way beyond Hillary
Clinton
we now have an investigation that in the
words of President Donald Trump from the
very beginning has been a fix a frame-up
and a witch-hunt
it was halide by Peter Strock who it is
disgraceful and even even for for the
present director of the FBI to have him
there tomorrow it would be disgraceful
every FBI agent should demand that that
man be fired and tomorrow Muller should
suspend his investigation and he should
go see rod Rosen see who created him and
the Deputy Attorney General and Attorney
General Sessions who'd met who should
now step up big time to save his
department should suspend that
investigation throw out all the people
that have been involved in the phony
Trump investigation and bring in honest
FBI agents from the New York office who
I can trust implicitly and they should
turn their attention to Comey struck
page all those FBI agents who took gifts
gifts Shawn that's called bribery where
I come from they took tickets to games
they put me governor McDonald in jail
the the angry Democrats who will work in
mahler they put governor McDonald in
jail for taking a couple of little
trinkets compared FBI agents selling out
and leaking like sibs
and then the statement of struck we're
gonna stop Donald Trump and he's put in
charge of the Russia investigation and
the guy that should be the head of this
RICO case is Jim Comey because he's the
one who created this atmosphere in the
Justice Department he's the reason that
struck was able to operate Paige was
able to operate those guys are taking
tickets if FBI agents should be
infuriated by that I'm inferior I love
the FBI these people don't love the FBI
I do yeah and I was just gonna say I
want to make sure the American people
understand this is not the rank-and-file
this was literally ripped out of the
hands of rank-and-file brought into the
seventh floor the upper echelon of the
FBI I guess the most important thing
here is especially from your perspective
in the president's perspective if you
treat one candidate one way and you
literally have crimes and the evidence
is incontrovertible I mean I never saw a
better case for obstruction than what
Hillary did to subpoena the leading acid
washing and breaking up devices if
you're gonna treat her that way and you
look at the the bully tactics that have
been put together by Weissman in the
beginning struck and the team Muller put
together how can any American at this
point not see that that is a dual system
of justice and that is a risk to our
entire constitutional republic
well I think Shawn I I feel that this
this whole thing has made fools of all
of us I mean they think we're idiots we
supplied 1.4 million documents we
supplied 32 witnesses no no privilege
arguments and who we supply them to
people who have already concluded to
frame Donald Trump agents who started a
phony Russia investigation that's the
whole core of this that's why the
investigation should be suspended and I
I'm talking for myself now not the
president
I believe he would agree with this a
very serious investigation has to be
done of the FBI agents at the very top
by FBI agents who were honest in order
to deny them for the American people
yeah we're there we're dropping the love
they had a Hillary it's all there in
black and white that's political why did
Horowitz say there's no evidence of
political bias when it's all over his
document I don't know I don't know what
Horowitz concluded I don't know what's
the FBI director concluded I'm beyond
that I think all the attention now
should be focused on let's get a fair
investigation of the people who
corrupted that investigation have been
engaged in a corruption investigation
from the beginning President Trump has
said over and over again to me I did
nothing wrong
how could this be well now we know how
it is
because these people fixed it that's how
it is
please American people listen to me read
this read this if you're not disgusted
and you don't demand that the just
Department begin this investigation and
suspend the one of the President and all
the people that have been tortured by it
then I don't think we have justice
anymore in this country last last point
rod Rosen Stein we now know in meetings
has threatened to subpoena emails
intimidate harassing congressmen and
their staffs who have been tasked
constitutionally with the duty of
oversight you know about these threats
and he's the guy that signed the last
FISA warrant knowing that the bulk of
information the phony Clinton paid-for
dossier and he's the guy that
recommended firing Comey so he's
conflicted but intimidating and
threatening to use the power of the
Justice Department against congressmen
and their staffs what do you call that
to me it sounds like obstruction yeah I
mean it's a lot more Excel or
obstruction then the firing call me on
his recommendation which is not
obstruction it's within the president's
Article two powers and so I believe that
rod Rosenstein and Jeff Sessions have a
chance to redeem themselves and that
chance comes about tomorrow doesn't go
beyond tomorrow tomorrow Muller should
be suspended and honest people should be
brought in impartial people to
investigate these people like struck
truck should be in jail by the end of
next week all right mr. mayor thank you
we'll follow this story and let's see if
you cooperate sign up to Mexican let's
see if he cooperates on Comey huh good
point